hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar titled
sorting out the mechanisms of endocytic
recycling this webinar is part of the
cell biology virtual event
and i'm susie valdez of labyrinths and i
will be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by the lab roots
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question
box and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation just
click on that
ask a question box located on the far
left of your screen
as a reminder this presentation is
educational and offers free continuing
education credits tab
credits click on the continuing
education credits
tab located on the top right corner of
your presentation window and follow
those processes
to get those credits i now present
today's speaker dr
steve kaplan professor and vice chair
for administration
department of biochemistry and molecular
biology
and the director of unmc advanced
microscopy core facility at the research
institute and he's also the program
coordinator for a complete biography
of our speaker please visit the
biography tab at the top of your screen
dr kaplan welcome you may now begin your
presentation sir
okay hello um thank you for the
introduction and good afternoon to
everyone
um today i will be taking through a
little bit of a journey that goes
and looks at basic mechanisms
of trafficking through the cell and
we'll be discussing
in particular mechanisms that control
the recycling of receptors from the
plasma membrane
receptors back to the plasma membrane
from inside the cell
so first off a little bit of a plug for
basic science
in these days when a lot of the science
that you hear about
tends to be what we call translational
and focused
exclusively on disease research and i'm
a big proponent of
basic biomedical science in curiosity
driven
and arthur kornberg nobel prize
recipient back in 1959 said
um no matter how counter-intuitive it
may seem
basic research has proven over and over
to be the lifeline of practical advances
in medicine
without advances medicine regresses and
reverts to witchcraft
and for this reason my laboratory and i
have been focusing
on our basic understanding of membrane
trafficking
and to start with i'll give you a little
bit of an overview about the
pathways that we study and then we'll
start to focus in
and i'll explain in more detail about
some of the more recent research we've
done in our lab
but this research has started out as a
journey built upon years and years of
research
by many other laboratories and basically
it addresses
these trafficking pathways of a receptor
such as the tfr or transfer and receptor
which is found on the plasma membrane
and it is internalized into the cell
when it binds its
its ligand which is transferred and
loaded with iron
and it's internalized into these
clathrin-coated pits that you can see
and
once the internalization occurs or once
these clouded coated pits are formed
there's an enzyme a basically a protein
that's involved in the fission of these
small coated vesicles and this fission
occurs
and a vesicle is released into the
cytoplasm
and the vesicles end up fusing with the
next organelle that you can see
along the list which is the endosome the
early endosome sorting endosome
and once this occurs these receptors in
this case
the example i'm using the transform
receptor are delivered to the
membrane of the endosome and they can
undergo
a number of different fates depending on
what receptor
they are in this case the transferrin
receptors typically returned
back to the plasma membrane through
mechanisms that
involve what we call recycling and this
is the return
of vesicles or small tubules containing
transfer and receptor right back to the
plasma membrane
where it can again undergo uh binding to
its ligand and the cycle can
occur again and again indefinitely until
eventually the receptor undergoes
degradation and new receptors replace it
on the plasma membrane however
this sorting into the recycling pathway
depending on the receptor and different
circumstances within the cell
can also lead the receptors in the
sorting endosome to be
sorted to different fates and the other
fate shown here on the left side of the
slide to the mvp or multivesicular body
and then on to the lysosome leads to the
degradation
of these specific receptors so a lot of
the research in
um in the area of of cell biology and
in my lab in particular is focusing on
understanding
um the mechanisms by which number one
receptors are sorted into their various
pathways their various fates for
degradation
or recycling at the endosome or
um or in addition to that i should say
also the mechanisms by which
those vesicles containing the receptors
are released from the endosome
so that they can be transported to one
fate or another fate
and those will be the central questions
that i'll be discussing today
now key to a lot of these trafficking
pathways
are a lot of different events that occur
obviously and a big family of proteins
known as the rab
family of gtp binding proteins uh you
can see a couple of examples of the
60 odd rab proteins that are known
uh in mammalian cells here we have rab5
and rab7 and rab4 and these are proteins
that play
key and important roles in the in the
transport in the
first of all in the in forging the
identity of the individual
endosomal and membrane bound
compartments in the endocytic pathways
but also in controlling the transport
from point to point
within these compartments so just as an
example rab11
is a key protein known to be involved in
controlling
recycling of receptors back to the
plasma membrane
so if we look at transport of
receptors from place to place within the
cell
we can look at this snare based fission
fusion
and transport of vesicles which brought
rothman and his colleagues
the nobel prize in in 2014
and this little schematic diagram kind
of illustrates for us
this mechanism in general so we have on
the left the donor compartment
which could be the plasma membrane but
in our case we're focusing on the
endosome so this would be the endosome
and we have the cargo molecules they
could be
soluble cargo that go inside the
vesicles or they could be transmembrane
receptors which
is something we're interested in and
these receptors
get into areas that form buds and you
can see these
buds have coats around them which are
proteins that
coat these areas of lipids that are kind
of budding off of the endosome
and at some point they form these sphere
usually spherical structures
that are the vesicles that will be
transported and they need to undergo
what we call
scission incision for scissors or
fission and the fission cleaves off
these vesicles
with the receptors in the membrane and
they're transported along
usually along microtubules with motor
proteins that are attached to them
and they drive these structures along
to the acceptor compartment which could
be
if this is an endosome this could be to
the back to the plasma membrane and
recycling
and there's a process of fusion that
occurs as a tethering step step
where these vesicles kind of are are
glued onto the
um the acceptor membrane by a series of
different interactions
and protein interactions and as a result
and the rabs play a key role in this and
as a result
other proteins known as snare proteins
are involved in
allowing these membranes to get close
enough and eventually
intercalate with one another and allow a
fusion event between the membranes
and that vesicle then becomes part of
the membrane of the acceptor membrane
and the receptor that was in that
membrane the vesicular membrane
is now part of the acceptor compartment
or in this case it's looking at it
the plasma membrane so this is basically
how most of the trafficking occurs
within cells
so in the course of um
the last couple of decades and the
research that um
that i've done and those in my lab have
done in fact this was still
as a postdoctoral fellow about 20 years
ago
um i began to work on a protein and i
won't get into the reasons for this but
a protein that we suspected was involved
in some of these pathways and really
hadn't been
characterized at the time i started to
work on it
and one of the first things that we did
was look at the localization
of this protein within cells and first
we
cloned the protein or cloned the cdna
and expressed the protein in cells
and we used electron microscopy
immunoelectron microscopy and found
the black cool dots that you see in a
and the immuno em and you know electron
microscopy
um surround this tubular-like structure
which essentially is a membrane-bound
structure
a membrane-bound tubular structure that
is a
type of an endosome which we realized uh
over time and when we express this
protein
as um in in immune fluorescence
experiments
the black structures that you see in b
are a gfp green fluorescent tag protein
of the hd1
and you can see those structures are
mostly these tubular structures
which really surprised us because for
the most part we expected maybe seeing
this on endosomes
but we didn't expect to see it on these
very wide and unusual looking
tubular based structures and we used the
technique which at the time was
was new and has become more common in
recent years
and this technique is called clam or
correlative light
and electron microscopy and this little
box that you can see and b
that shows a part of a tubular recycling
endosome in it
has been used and cut
serial sections of that to look at it
for electron microscopy
and you can see the black peroxidase
dots are surrounding that very same
tubule that you can see there in the box
this is the plasma membrane
that you can see where it says pm out in
the corner
and the m marks a mitochondria to the
left of this tubular recycling endosome
and this is not just an artifact of over
expressing over expressing
because we can actually made an antibody
for ehd1
and we can see that it marks in these
hela cells on the left
it marks tubular and vesicular
structures in white
now that seem to be in an area that's
perinuclear or or very close to the
nucleus
or one side of the nucleus at least so
we have a protein that has a
as an unusual localization to these
tubular structures
for the most part and we began thinking
about these structures over
over the coming years because they're
very unusual
and in recent years there's been more
and more attention paid to these
networks of tubular structures which in
many cases
actually bud out of the early or sorting
endosome
and this uh this diagram here this
cartoon basically shows tubular
structures that are coated or marked by
various different proteins in this case
proteins known as sorting nexons mix 27
snakes 3
snakes 4 and other snakes proteins that
belong to the retromer complex
for the most part and these are often
uh tubular structures that bud from
these endosomes as shown by the work of
peter cullen
and and others and um we
have began to try and make sense of
these tubular recycling
endosomes and understand what their
function is
and kind of skipping ahead or giving you
a kind of a premonition for
where we're going with this we believe
that this ehd1 protein is intimately
involved not in generating these tubular
recycling endosomes but
in cleaving them and serving as a
molecular scissors
involved in fission of these structures
so that they can allow recycling to
occur back to the plasma membrane so
back when we began
studying ehd1 and trying to understand
its function
we used a rather simple kind of assay to
determine if it's involved in membrane
trafficking
and recycling to the plasma membrane
about the time we
we did these studies it was we're coming
out of the lab of
barth grant at rutgers university
showing that a homolog free hd1 and c
elegans
appears to be involved in the recycling
um in uh calan uh in in
basically in cells from the intestine of
c elegans
and so this was our hypothesis and we
began working on this
and the way that we study this is quite
simple
we use the same transfer and that i
showed you in the very initial
initial slides it's capable of taking up
being taken up through its receptor
transfer receptor into cells
and we use a fluorophore labeled
transfer and a dye labeled transferrin
that goes into the cells and it goes
into the cells
um we allow it into the cells for 15 or
20 minutes
and then we wash out any
non-internalized
dye label transfer and by adding
unlabeled transferrin
to the cells and then we follow how long
it takes for the transfer
to disappear from the cells as a measure
of recycling so
what you're looking at on the left hand
side are cells on the bottom
that have taken up transferrin and
released their transferrin and basically
the recycling has occurred you can see a
little bit of white lift
in these cells that i've marked with the
yellow outline
and on top this just shows schematically
what we're looking at cells that are
basically
almost empty of transfer and after about
30 minutes of allowing recycling
we then used what was more or less a
relatively new technique at the time
uh silencing rna to knock down the
levels of ehd1
shown in this western blot and you can
see that the
hd1 is almost completely gone in the
knockdown cells and then we repeated the
same experiment
essentially to see what happens to the
transfer that was taken up into the cell
does it recycle to the same degree and
when we studied this what we could see
in the bottom right you can see that the
transferrin
um the label transfer and still bound to
its receptor
accumulates within the cells in this
perinuclear region
um in this kind of blob of transfer
these are endosomes
that basically the transference hasn't
been released from them
and this kind of suggests that eht-1
knockdown um fails to allow
recycling to occur to the same degree
that it occurs in
in normal cells and suggests that it
plays a role in regulating recycling
in a mechanism that at the time we
didn't fully understand and i think
we're coming to terms with understanding
better uh now and i'll come to that
towards the end of my talk
so just to complicate things it turns
out that there are
four proteins with a good degree of
homology
uh really identity to one another that
are part of a family of proteins in
mammalian cells
called ehd one two three and four the
two closest proteins are ehd1 and eht3
with
about 86 identity at the amino acid
level
many people would say these are almost
the same protein essentially
but i will briefly show you that they
have what we think are
different maybe partially overlapping
but different functions
um and i really won't be talking about
eht2 and hd4 today to any degree
but there are four of them um and this
is interesting because in c
elegans and drosophila there's only a
single
eht-1 although there are some different
isoforms
but it's essentially the same protein in
yeast
um there are no eht proteins or eht
proteins from the same family at least
uh suggesting it's a relatively new
evolutionary
invention um in eukaryotic cells
so what is the hd1 and
and what is its domain architecture look
like
and if we look at the schematic diagram
up in the top left
we can see that this family of proteins
has essentially
an atp binding g domain sandwiched
between a couple of helical domains
and then another domain at the
c-terminus
which kind of gives the protein its name
which is an eh
domain or eps 15 homology domain based
on its homology 2
family of about oh 35 to 50 different
proteins that have a domain
that has a similar structure and similar
um or at least uh homologous amino acid
residues
it's about a hundred amino acid domain
and it
um is known to be involved in binding as
a protein binding module
it binds to proteins that contain the
following tripeptide motif
asparagine proline phenylalanine or npf
and so it's an interesting protein
binding
module the crystal structure was first
solved by the lab of harvey mcmahon
in cambridge and he showed it for the
mouse ehd2
and basically what he showed is that
there are lipid binding interfaces
there is this atp hydrolysis domain
binding and hydrolysis domain
and the eh domains are kind of adjacent
to one another and they're they're in a
dimeric
type of structure we later
solved the um eh domain by
nmr solution structure
in order to address some specific
questions about the
eh domain and get a better understanding
of how it differs
from the eh domains found in other
proteins from different families
and i'll be coming to that in a moment
because it's an interesting thing and so
what we've found
is that there are some interesting
differences between
this eh domain um or actually the four
eh domains of these
c terminal ehd family members and
um eh domains in general and if we take
a look at that
um it allowed us to ask questions about
the basis
of selectivity for how ehd1
m2 3 and 4 bind to specific subsets of
proteins
whereas other members of the family that
have an eh domain
bind to very different proteins and so
if we take a look at this
this is as i showed you the type of
domain architecture that we have for the
what we call the c-terminal eht proteins
because the h domain
is at the c-terminus whereas the many
other
members of this family that have eh
domains
are n-terminal eht proteins they have
one or more eh domains at the n-terminus
and they behave very differently because
they bind to different subsets of
proteins
and why is that the case and this is one
of the questions that we were really
interested in and given
the structural knowledge that we were
able to um
to obtain from the nmr solution
structure
we were able to come up with an
interesting hypothesis
what we found is that if we compare on
the right the eh domain of the hd1
with other n-terminal eh domains
we find that there's a lot more blue
positively charged residues on the
surface of the
c-terminal ehd proteins and a lot more
negatively charged structures on the
surface in the n-terminal ehd proteins
and so if we look at this at a kind of
more
molecular level and identify maybe six
of the key residues on the surface
that would be involved in the binding
and we look at
various in fact five different
n-terminal eh domains
we find when we look at the six residues
that the net
charge is either very mildly positive
or negatively charged or close to
neutral
um when we look at the c-terminal ehd
proteins ehd one
two three and four on the left and then
the xenopus
drosophila c elegans zebrafish
and schistosomula eht proteins we find
each of the eh domains there have very
strongly
positively charged resins and that
all led us to hypothesize
something very interesting based on
another observation that
we had made and this observation is that
if we look at
proteins that we and others have
identified that bind to the c-terminal
ehd zhd-123 and iv
we find that after the npf motif in
these proteins
that binds to the h domain there
typically
are a number of acidic or negatively
charged residues that follow the npf
motif
whereas proteins that show weak or no
binding to the c-terminal ehds
but do bind to the n-terminal ehds
typically have very little or no acidic
residues that are
immediately following the npf motifs and
that's shown on the bottom
and so this all led us to an interesting
hypothesis
that perhaps the positively charged
surface area
of the c-terminal eh domains the ht-1234
allows interactions or better
interactions with
npf motifs that are followed by
negatively charged residues such as
e and d and that was our hypothesis
and one of the students in my laboratory
at the time
sharma who now has a lab of her own um
she was able to show an interaction
between ehd1 and a new protein that
hadn't really been
um characterized yet called macall l1
and interestingly macale 1 has not one
but two npf motifs
and one of those npf motifs but not the
other one
had no less than six acidic
residues following the npf motif and so
that to us was interesting because
immediately if we wanted to test our
hypothesis
we thought that ehd1 may interact with
macale 1
through the first npf motif but not
through the second one because only the
first one has
the negatively charged residues and so
we tested that by making mutations
in cali1 and basically removing the
second npf motif mutating it to
apa instead of npf and then
addressing what happens when we leave
the first npf motif alone
or make mutations in it so we use the
gst
pull-down system at first to pull down
um either wild-type macall one
and we could see that it came down
nicely in the left lane
then we pulled down macadam one with the
second npf
motif mutated the one with no acidic
residues
and we find we still get in the second
lane very nice pull down
but when we take that same mutant that
has
no second npf motif and in the first npf
motif change all of the
acidic residues to alanine we lose the
vast majority of the binding
and we'd lose a lot of the binding if we
change the first three
acidic residues to alanine unless
we'd lose less of the bindings we'd
change only the second three to alanine
and we didn't stop there we did the same
type of experiment
using the yeast two hybrid system um
which basically the yeast will grow
only if there's an interaction and what
we showed is that
eht-1 colonies of the
eht-1 mikala 1 grew when the mikala 1
was wild-type
but when we transformed with a macalla 1
lacking the first npf motif the one with
the acidic residues there was no
uh growth therefore no binding and when
we
knocked down the second npf motif and
did this no effect on the binding so
very consistent with what we showed with
the gst
pull down and then again the same thing
when we knock down the
acidic residues we lose the binding we
knock down the first three acidic
residues
lose most of the binding knock down the
second three acidic residues we lose
some but
not all of the binding so very
consistent
and in um in agreement with that we did
further
nmr titration studies and i won't go
through this but just say that the
titration curves uh fully support the
data
from the two hybrid and gst pull-down
studies
showing that essentially these acidic
residues following the mpf
are needed for optimal binding affinity
in this assay
and in agreement with that also
the group of uh jim alecha at tufts
university
also published about the same time our
paper came out
a paper of their own completely
independent using
a fourth system is a thermal titration
calorimetry
and essentially showed the same results
that we were showing so we felt
very confident to say that the mechanism
for selective binding
of these c-terminal eh domains on ehd-1
and its fellow members with
[Music]
npf-containing proteins really
requires these acidic clusters
so in fitting with all of those
we have been over the years interested
in identifying interaction partners to
further understand the function
of eht-1 and its partners in
regulating and acidic recycling and
figuring out how
it controls endocytic recycling and this
is a partial list of some of the
proteins
that we found that interact we and
others have found it interact
with ehd1 and its partners and the ones
with the stars are ones that we
identified
some of them are identified by their
labs and i don't think this is a
complete list
and today i'm going to be telling you
about a new protein that we've
identified that
interacts with the hd1 independently
of the eh domain and npf motifs
so just to kind of further um draw out
the rule that
there's now becoming a consensus about
for understanding ehd-1 and its function
several years ago um in collaboration
with
um way glow's lab in um
in the university of pennsylvania um we
were trying to understand what the hd1
function was and some results that we
had
seem to suggest that eht-1 may be
involved in fission
as a vesiculator of these tubular
recycling endosomes that
um that i'm showing you here so these
are tubular recycling endosomes marked
by the very protein we discussed mccall
l1 you can see a cluster of cells there
may be 10 cells in this field
the nuclei or the dark areas and these
white
structures that you see are marked by
macallo1 these are what we call the tre
or tuber
tubular recycling endosomes when we
knock down
ehd1 um in these cells
what we see is an expansion of the
tubular recycling endosome network
the tubules are longer they're more
diverse they're more numerous
and there's a greater volume of these
structures in cells
surprisingly when we knock down the
closest homolog to ehd1 which is eht3
we see a loss of these structures all
together and i don't really have time to
tell you about
ehd 3's rule today but we do know that
eht3 is involved in controlling or
allowing
these structures to be maintained rather
than
involved in their vesiculation and we
can show that if you
transfect
[Music]
if you transfect we're having issues
with the
slide here
let's see
there we go so if you transfect ehd1
back into cells that are knocked down
for ehd3 if you transfect the ehd3 back
using a mutant that's not knocked down
by the sirna
you can see that it restores the tubules
that are marked by macall l1 in this
case
so that's ehd3 important for the
maintenance of these tubular recycling
endosomes now how do we study these
structures
we study them by quantifying them in a
variety of different manners
this particular image just shows you
how we can basically translate what we
see by immune fluorescence
into something that we can measure by
image j and we can count the number of
tubules
in a field of cells 123 in this case and
the total
tubular area in two-dimensional images
as we
have done here and what we can basically
see is when we knock down the hd1 and
let's ignore the
other ehd proteins in this graph so when
we compare the
mock on the left to the ehd1si rna
we can see that the count the number of
tubules per field
increases by about twofold with the hd1
knockdown
you see the opposite uh with the hd3
knockdown
and when we measure the um the base
basically the the
square area the micron squared uh
of tubules that we find the total area
we can see that there's also a
two plus four increase when we knock
down the hd1
suggesting that eht-1 may no longer be
trimming or cutting
these structures so um
our our hypothesis now and it's it's
basically a hypothesis that many
groups now hold and many groups have
worked on this is that ehd1 induces
fission
and um here's another experiment
that we did that we did in collaboration
with wei guo at pennsylvania u
pennsylvania
and basically it's a simple experiment
where we take
purified ehd1 and we add it to liposomes
and do electron microscopy analysis and
we add it to liposomes in the presence
or absence of atp and as i mentioned
it's an atpase it needs
atp in order to function to hydrolyze
atp
and carry out its enzymatic activity
and so what you can see on the left is a
micrograph in
a where you've got some large liposomes
or larger liposomes with no atp
when we add atp typically the size of
these
liposomes is decreased due to fission
that occurs by ehd1 in the presence of
atp
and through counting many many um
[Music]
slides like this we've come to the
conclusion that the
ehd1 plus atp again decreases the size
the mean size of these liposomes of
diameter by about
um you know twofold or so so this is
more evidence that it's involved in
fission
and our our essential thoughts are and i
won't go again through this whole idea
but these are the tubular
endosomes that we think that to some
degree mccall l1
and syndapan may be involved in their
generation by binding to
phosphatidic acid and data i'm not
showing you today
and receptors are sorted along these
tubular um
recycling endosomes and at some point
eht-1 is recruited
that's the e recruited through its
binding to machal1 and syndapan
and is able to cleave uh
these tubular endosome tubular recycling
endosomes into vesicles that are now
released
allowing for the recycling of receptors
back to the plasma membrane
so this is an interesting experiment
that really
highlights the um the molecular
mechanism of ehd1 it was done by the
group of thomas pookadil
um in in india and uh at pune in india
and this is a beautiful experiment where
he's taken um membranes that are marked
by
fluorescent lipids and kind of stretch
them along
into tubules and by adding ehd1 with
purified
purified ehd1 with atp what he can show
is that over time
you start to see this is 78 seconds in
the middle panel here you can start to
see where those arrows are showing
areas that are prone to fission where
the eht-1
is involved in the cleavage or the
fission of these membrane structures
the other areas shown by white are areas
where we get the
thickening of the membrane where ehd1
probably accumulates
to exert force on the membrane and this
is what what he shows down below
in what he calls this barbell model
where you get the accumulation of ehd1
sitting on both sides
of the area that is prone to undergo
fission
and through hydrolysis activity
ultimately that
membrane is cleaved allowing the tubule
to
break into small tubules or vesicles
and allow as we know recycling to occur
so there's very strong evidence that the
hd1 is involved in fission
from from many groups now so the
question that i really want to talk
about today in the next
uh 10 15 minutes or so
is new data from our lab discussing
how we think fission by e-mediated by
uhd1
connects with the sorting of receptors
at these endosomes and so that's the key
question how is sorting mediated and we
know that
receptors go into these areas of the
endosomal membrane
that bud and ultimately undergo fission
and so one of the families of proteins
that in recent years has been described
as playing key roles in
sorting are a family of proteins um
not uh surprisingly known as sorting
nexons with snakes
proteins and i won't go through all of
these different
sorting necks and proteins that have
been discovered
with homology to one another and and
many of them bind membranes and can
sense membranes and even induce membrane
curvature
one of these proteins that we're
particularly interested in for a variety
of reasons
is called snips 17.
and the reasons for this is that snick
17
through the work of peter cullen
and a variety of dan bilodeau and
variety of other labs
um um have shown
that snick-17 seems to play a role in
the recycling of various
receptors back to the plasma membrane
again in a mechanism that isn't entirely
clear
rather like ehd1 um so that that kind of
rang a bell for us we've got two
proteins
both involved at endosomes and both play
rules in recycling somehow
and so we were asking how sneak 17
mediates its interaction with a wide
range of cargos
and this in the literature has been
shown and this is a
a study structural study by brett
collins
um who showed basically the
three-dimensional structure
crystal structure of uh snake 17
and it basically has a px or a lipid
binding domain you can see that
on the right in the bottom area binding
to lipids in the membrane
and it also has what's called a firm
domain which has different
lobes in it but overall the firm domain
binds to
receptor tails to various sequences of
receptor tails
in this particular case it's a sequence
made up of
np any amino acids any amino acid and
why it's tyrosine
or in any amino acid any amino acid
tyrosine so either of these two types of
motifs
and receptors that have these motifs
will interact
many times with the firm domain of snake
17. so it's kind of linked
to the membrane in two different ways
and so what we're thinking is that this
nyx protein is able to interact at
endosomes 617
with certain receptors that need to
undergo recycling based on this kind of
interaction with their receptor tails
but there needs to be a protein that's
involved in the fission
of these vesicles and basically
that brings us to our thoughts about
ehd1
so we know that both the hd1 and snik17
control recycling
and we know that ehd1 depletion causes
impaired recycling of
a variety of different receptors
snick-17 depletion
causes impaired recycling of many of the
same receptors
and since eht-1 doesn't interact to the
best of our knowledge
with the majority of these receptors
maybe
the snick 17 links eht-1 to these cargo
to allow fission and their recycling
back to the plasma membrane
and all of that brings us to the
hypothesis that i'm going to take you
through today
is that we have a sorting endosome we
have a receptor shown in brown here
um and we have the snick 17 allowing
that receptor to be pulled into this
budding region that needs to undergo
fission
and perhaps the snick 17 is able to
interact with the hd1
and maybe even recruit it to this region
that needs to undergo fission
and ehd1 will release the vesicle from
recycling back to the plasma membrane
so that's our hypothesis and to answer
this we first ask does nik17
interact with the hd1 and we first
resorted to immunoprecipitations
and we show here that um snake 17
immunoprecipitation with snake17 pulls
down itself
and immunoprecipitation with ehd1
pulls down snick-17 and a control
eb3 doesn't pull down um snake-17
it does pull down itself and so this was
the first indication that these proteins
interact with one another
in cells and we next ask do they
interact directly and to do this we need
to
uh first purify proteins so we can test
whether they interact
in a controlled environment and we used
his tag the hd1 which we purified and
that's shown in the left panel
and basically we used another purified
protein
gst as a control and gst attached to
snake 17
as our experiment so to speak and what
you see in the middle panel
is that when we use gst we do not
pull down any snake 17 but when we use
g i'm sorry when we use gst we do not
pull down any um
um i'm sorry when we use ehd1 to pull
down
um either gst or gst snick 17
we do not pull down any gst and that's
the gst express there we pull down
nothing
but when we use ehd1 to pull down the
gst next 17
we pull down a lot of snik17 suggesting
that these two proteins interact
in in vitro and that their interaction
may be direct
we went on to try and characterize the
domains that interact
and just very very briefly to take you
through this
what we showed again was that the eht
one the
uh his tag the hd1 beads pulled down
gst snick 17 but they also pulled down
um the firm b this region up on top on
the
middle left of the protein and the
um firm c lobe um in an experiment i'm
not showing you here
we use the px domain which was purified
and showed that that did not
come down with the hd1 so we know it's
the firm domain
the whole firm domain apparently appears
to be capable
of of binding
so what drives the hd1 to the endosomal
membrane this is a protein that's found
both in the cytoplasm and on
endosomal membranes and very briefly
what we showed is that when we
do an uptake experiment we add ligand
and allow receptors to be taken up into
cells
um we basically see that the snick 17 is
already on endosomes for the
most part so you're looking here in c
and d at the insets on the left
at the endosomes that you can see
containing snake 17.
however when we look at eht-1 we see
that there's really very little ehd-1 on
endosomes there's some of it on
endosomes
but when we add lrp-1 uptake this is a
low density lipoprotein-like receptor
what we basically see uh is that more
eht-1 is found
on these endosomal structures suggesting
that
the recruitment of eht-1 to endosomes
occurs
when receptors are taken up into the
cell
and we can measure this by doing
quantitative microscopy
and as you can see in the left panel the
total eht-1 surface volume
on these endosomal structures is
dramatically increased
when we do the lrp-1 uptake it is
increased a little bit
for snick 17 but relatively minor
compared to the ht-1
does lrp-1 uptake increase the
co-localization between the hd1 and
seventeen
we would expect that to be the case
because
if eht-1 is recruited to endosomes where
snake 17 is
we would expect more once the hd1
arrives at endosomes so we did this
experiment
and what you're seeing here is the
quantification
and we see more overlap between pixels
that contain
ehd1 and snyx17 with the lrp1 uptake
below is shown a representative image
for how this looks now these are
three-dimensional slices that we've
taken and use the ameris
program to essentially
render them into surface volumes so that
we can look at overlap of surfaces so
we're removing
the non-membrane bounds cytosolic haze
of these proteins
and what you can see with no uptake um
compared to uptake
is that there's a lot more yellow shown
on the bottom right compared to the top
right
um and and that it means that we're
we're having more overlap between hd1
and 617
when we induce receptor mediated uptake
this shows you the 3d
image with no uptake so there is a
modicum the yellow
pixels that you can see there represent
the overlap
and you can see there's certainly a
degree of overlap even with no uptake
because receptors are always being
taken up to some degree but when we do
the uptake
you can see that there's considerably
more yellow representing the overlap
of the surface volume between ehd1
and snik17 so does
ehd1 require snake17 for endosomal
recruitment in other words is nix 17 the
anchor for ehd1
on endosomes and the answer to that is
probably
no and we know that because
we take mock cells mock-treated cells
and we do lrp-1 uptake and you can see
that there's an increase
in ehd1 recruitment shown in the inset
on the right in panel b when we knock
down the snick 17
if the snick 17 was needed for
recruitment we would expect in panel d
to see almost no ehd1 being recruited
but since it is recruited
as measured here you can see the
increase
compared to no uptake and the bottom
graph is very similar to what you see
for the mock same type of increase and
all of this suggests that
snake 17 knockdown has very little
impact on ehd-1's recruitment to
endosomes meaning it most likely
doesn't recruit ehd-1 so finally if ehd1
regulates endosome fission would we
expect to see an increase in endosomal
size if we deplete the hd1 from cells
and we used our crispr
cast 9 ehd 1
knockdown cells and and crispr cast 90
hd1 gfp
tag cells to kind of compare what
happens
in cases where we knocked down ehd1 um
so in other words here are the kind of
parental cells that you see here the hd1
gfp cells
and you can see this is the um
this is the level that you can see of
snick 17 the size of the stick 17
endosomes that you see
on the left here in the inset and you
can see with the knockdown of ehd1 that
there are certainly some endosomes
that appear to be of larger size in
these cells the gels here on the right
basically show that these cell lines are
indeed
what we have and finally these graphs
here
are automated measurements that we've
done of the mean
interval of endosomal size plotted and
so the top graph shows the frequency
which you can essentially
see is that in the ehd1 knockdown cells
the mean interval of endosomal size is
decreased or shifted a little bit to the
right
indicating that the endosome size is
typically larger
in the absence of ehd1 basically because
there's a failure to undergo fission
so these endosomes tend to just
accumulate lipids but not
get rid of them and then they grow in
size if we do this
by relative frequency out of a 100
percent
what you can basically see is the shift
to the right is is a lot more dramatic
and we really see a pretty dramatic
increase
in endosome size as a result of the hd1
knockdown
so basically to summarize our model
for what i've shown you today depicting
the mechanisms for eht-1 recruitment
is that when we have lrp1 this receptor
bound to its ligand being taken up into
endosomes
into vesicles or endosomes basically the
lrp1
arrives at an endosome and is sorted by
snyk17
to an area of the endosome that is
budding and
set to undergo fission back to the
plasma membrane
and we think that this ligand binding
somehow releases signals within the cell
that may
induce eht-1 to be recruited to these
endosomes
we don't know what the signal is whether
it's atp binding
phosphorylation dimerization
ubiquitalation there are various
different
potential mechanisms that we're looking
at now for recruitment of ehd1
to these endosomes but the recruitment
occurs by
an eeip or ehd1 or endosomal eht-1
interaction partner
and not through snake 17 but later the
eht-1
somehow is moved along the endosomal
membrane
where it comes into contact with
snake-17
and allows the fission to occur at this
constriction region
release of this budding vesicle
and it's recycling back to the plasma
membrane
so loss of either eht-1 or snick-17
in this way would account for a
[ __ ] recycling of receptors back to
the plasma membrane
and i'd just like to thank all of the
people involved in the research that i
have shown today
i won't go through them all but i'll
point out that um
the the one of the the students that's
been primarily
involved in this most recent body of
work kenica
has done a lot of the um really
important experiments in
understanding how snick 17 interacts
with the hd1
to carry out these fission studies and
i'd like to thank the
funding institutions for uh providing us
with the funding
that we could do for this work and i'll
just finally
say that um if anybody is interested
in learning about the lives of
scientists in laboratories
um these are four novels that i've
written that deal with fictional
characters
at different scientific institutions in
north america and they're all available
by amazon online if if anybody shows any
interest
and thank you very much for your
interest and i'll be happy to take any
questions
for that informative presentation we
will now
turn to the live portion of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen so let's get started
we already have some great
questions coming in dr kaplan
does the early endosome uptake clathrin
form the coated pills
i'm sorry the coated pits
i'm sorry what's the question what about
the coated pits does the earth
take clathrin form the coated
pits so the the clathrin-coated pits
are typically formed at the plasma
membrane and
um they are involved they're recruited
by a complex of proteins called the
adapter complex
ap2 proteins and they form those coated
pits that are internalized
um it's typically thought that these
vesicles undergo
encoding where the clathrin and the ap2
leave these vesicles prior to their
fusion with the endosomes
and then at endosomes and lysosomes and
at the golgi
there are definitely reports that
clathrin is involved
in forming the initial budding
structures that come out of those
membrane compartments as well
thank you so much and is it possible to
apply the tf
flow assay to flow cytometry
um to apply which which athlete of flow
cytometry
tf um
transferent assay that we were doing um
so flow cytometry is uh is a
terrific method that i didn't show any
data with that today but it's a terrific
method for quantitatively analyzing
how much of a given receptor or ligand
is taken up into the cell and sometimes
also either degraded or recycled back to
the plasma membrane
because it can give you instantaneous
information
at different kinetic time points um to
tell you how much fluorescence you have
within the cell
so typically labeled transferrin or
floor dye
uh dye label transferrin taken up into
the cell what we will do is we'll take
it up into the cell
and then we'll measure how much
fluorescence we have in the cell at
that what we call the zero time point
and that's our hundred percent so if the
fluorescence gives
that gives us uh a value of a thousand
then we allow the cells to um
just live in culture for another 10
minutes 15 minutes one hour
and at each time point we can measure
how much transferring is left
and that will be a measure of how
quickly the recycling is occurring
so if we started with 1 000 and after 15
minutes
we now have only 200 and we've recycled
80
of our transferrin um within that period
of time because the transfer binds very
tightly to the receptor
and they cycle the cell together as a
complex
it's only the iron that the transference
is bound to that's released in the
endosome
thank you very much dr kaplan and again
i want to thank our audience members for
these great questions coming in
our next audience member wants to know
do you think that
yeast irs and tax 4 are ehd
homologs an excellent question
and um i really don't know i mean
um they do have some homology and there
have been some reports that they
may play rules similar to the mammalian
ehd proteins in yeast
but they're not classic homologs in that
they don't um
i guess they don't have all of the
domains that eht-1 has i mean if you
look in plants for example
which i don't know if they're farther
away than c elegans or not i guess they
are they're plants
um they they have the same um
domain architecture vht1 but they're
reversed
in other words the eh domain is at the
end terminus
and the is in the middle the atp's
region is in the middle
and the helical domains are at the
c-terminus so it's really the same
structure it's just kind of been flipped
um but the the tax irs proteins in east
don't really have all of those same
domains so i'm not sure they'd be really
exactly the same
thank you very much now many times polar
residues are responsible for the
specificity
rather than the affinity do you think
that the npf's
acidic clusters mediate specificity as
well
and this is two-part question perhaps
the mutations make them
no more specific for ehds anymore
well i think no i think that's a good
question and i think it's it's entirely
possible um and we don't even know for
example
what the specificity
is between the individual four eht
proteins eft one two three and four
all of them tend to prefer acidic
clusters
following the npf motif however there
are some preferences so for example the
hd1
appears to be able to bind a wider range
of proteins that contain
um npf ee or dd motifs
than um than the others like ehg4 or eh
iii and um it's
it's interesting that slight changes in
the
in the structure from what we know
between the ht1 and the predicted
structure of ehd3 because we don't have
the full solution structure
may um suggest that the one has a wider
binding pocket and is
slightly more capable of interacting now
having said that
um it's not entirely clear that the hd1
can't
bind you know proteins that have an npf
with no acidic residue there may be
binding but i think the
the affinity is much lower in those
cases and that's
that's consistent with what we see from
the titration
nmr titration and what um jim ballet
saw with the uh isoelectric
isothermal calorimetry experiments that
he did
thank you so much and we have time for
two more questions
dr kaplan do these ehd1
snx17 endosomes
colon collides with known early
recycling
endosomal markers and are there other
npf proteins that localize with a
snx 17.
great question i'll start with the
second part first um
yes there are other um and there are
other npf containing proteins
um rubensen5 for example is a marker of
early sorting endosomes and it's also
found in partial overlap with
snake 17 and there are others as well
um we'll go through them but there are
others as well um the second question
or the first part of the question if i'm
not mistaken was
um are there receptors that are
localizing with can can you read again
the first part of the question i'm sorry
sure no no problem the question was
does these ehd1
whoops i apologize it just got moved
do these ehd1 snake17
endosomes co-localize with known early
recycling
industrial markers okay yes absolutely
they do
um it's it's not a complete overlap or
co-localization it's a subset
so there are a number of markers and i
guess the second part of the question
partially answered the first part that's
why i got confused the benozin five
is both an npf containing protein it has
five npf motifs
it interacts with the hd1 and it also
co-localizes
at early sorting endosomes in part with
snik17
and with the hd one of those structures
and there are a variety of
other non-npf containing
early endosomal markers that also
collocalize with snake 17
in particular the retromer complex um
which is a whole complex of
proteins that's found involved in
sorting at early endosomes it's a master
regulator of trafficking
and it also overlaps many of the
proteins that make up that complex
overlap with with sneak 17 at least in
part
thank you so much our final question is
snick
17 relate to recycling
um secretary robs like 4 eleven and
eight or
sub-complexes of the retro or alike
yeah well sneak 17 has been i i'm not
sure
um with the ravs um exactly
how the snake 17 and the rabs fit into
the same
scenario it could be that grab seven on
endosomes may be involved in
recruiting parts of the retromer but at
the same time
the snake 17 seems to be independent of
the
overall general retromer that that
people were studying up until
a couple of years ago um and thinking
that might be part of this next 17
complex it turns out there's another
complex called the retriever complex
which is related to the retromer parts
of the proteins are
overlapping with those of the retromer
and this retriever complex
is really involved in binding to snake17
and that's probably the more important
protein complex
that's involved in sorting
dr kaplan thank you again for your time
today and for your important research
before we go i also want to thank the
audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions and questions we did not have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided
at the time of registration and this
webcast
can be viewed on demand for six months
until march
2021. elaborates will alert you via
email when it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time take
care
stay healthy bye